[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長ですはいちょっとまあ報告というかを剃らせというか何人か
ちょっと気になっている方もいると思うんですけども
a 実は昨日ですね
夜の夜のずうにジャン日深夜の12時半に警察の方に呼ばれて朝5時半くらいまで
警察署に言いました俺が捕まったんじゃねーぞあ僕が捕まっただそういうわけじゃない
んですけども
もうちょっと機能いろいろありましてまあこういうこともあったよっていうかなんか
まあこのあったことはなかった頭にするのを嫌だったんでまぁちょっとこういうことが
あったよってのちょっと皆さんにお知らせしようと思いますまあの簡単に説明しますと
実は
ストーカーの被害に遭いましたん
軟鉄よ
じゃねえ飯 ufo めでとダウンあるぞ
はいというわけでですねあの実は僕も家に監視カメラを仕掛けておりましてミニック
もうちょっと防犯ちゃんとしなきゃでも家がバレちゃってるからもう防犯ガチでやっ
てるから家のは連日は監視カメラはなんだったしかけていますこんな感じですね
こういう感じでもなんかカメラ動かしで出来るからねデコメもできるして常に録画はさ
れています
時間モデルとなるであの実はですね
おくんちの周りに来た人とかいるとも全員薫化してありますからあんまりちょっと俺ん
家に来るのはお勧めしないと思いますよ僕は住所がわかってもねで感じに昨日ずっと
コードが編集してたんですけどなんかちょっと7時夜の7時枚くらいに便本をンって
なって監視カメラ見たら知らない人が立ってました
うわっっ
と思ってまぁちょっと飯したんですけど
ピンポンがずっと
連絡されて挙句の果てにはドアが茶が崎字型されている家のまでぐるぐる回られたら
まだを取ってくれなんか最終的には玄関の前に座り込まれたりして結構怖かったです
ハイ
いや笑う所で山ならどこじゃなくて本当に怖かったです
一時間ほどずっとなんか家の前にいられてこれやべーなと思ってインターホンて帰って
ください的なことを言ったんですけど帰れないということを言われたのでも女子校です
ね型度地方させていただきました
そっからなんすよそうが長かった旧札来るまでずっと待って撮影来たら来たで事情聴取
が始まってもうなんかすげー長い頭が事情聴取とか編んでも動かないし
今回は何をされなかったんですけどベンチャーとネットなんか警察署に連れて帰って
すごい
奢られてもう二度とすんじゃねーぞ俺
リゾートしないでねみたいな数で言われたんですけどまぁそれでも期間なかった場合
もっと中にエスカレートしてなんか
家のものとか怖されて味したらそれこそも事件になるんでというのを防ぐため員に
えっと何か特別な処置みたいなことを球団の方にしてもらって
禁止命令というなんかこうてき高速を
していただいておりました錦糸名でっていうのがその今回での前にいた人が今後もう
一応
署名はだしてなんか所長さんにも通ったらしいのでもし今後その人が僕に近づいたり
何かしたりもう何でも何かした瞬間
一発逮捕らしいです側対歩直訳登板でもなんかパトがと聞いてザマッチ
構えられるらしいんでとりあえずはまあ安心はできないんですけど何とかなったかなと
いうところであるんですけどもやっぱり2されてるって言う間にば食べたりすると出て
ないじゃないですかいいえからどうしようもなくて城南海円高に何か友達とか言ったん
ですけど
かなか koa 買った数例3のなんか禁止命令の書類を書く度に警察署に連れてかれ
て
朝の5時半までそれ
書いた地蔵ちょっとされたり監視カメラの映像を一緒に見たりいろんな手続きをしてい
た一日でございました
はいというわけでえーマジで言い訳でした
なんか初めてちゃんとこういうストーカーみたいなことされてすごい怖かったんだよく
わかんないんですけど何か
youtube でこういうことがたまにあるみたいなのでまず普通に容赦なく通報と
かしますのでこういう行為はやめてくださいもし今度その人が軟化してきたらすぐそこ
逮捕なんだよいやもう何か怖いですよねを育てるでもうちょっとこうですよ
そんな航空ないけど皆さん雨な人には気をつけましょうねじゃバイバーイ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ